cuál podemos decir que es ese legado que
ha dejado el kirchnerismo
en primer lugar creo que la ampliación
de en su momento derechos y
fundamentalmente de accesos al consumo
que la vicepresidenta siempre se encarga
de recordar el punto es que el el futuro
del kirchnerismo está en el pasado
porque ella recuerda permanentemente las
tres presidencias la de su marido Néstor
kirchner y las dos que se dieron en el
periodo 2015 pero toma una distancia que
hoy volvió a ser explícita doblemente
con el actual presidente no considera
este Un gobierno que era seguido los
postulados del kirchnerismo y de hecho
el propio presidente de la república no
fue invitado a participar de esta
reunión de a quién más la vicepresidenta
es la que retoma el eje de la campaña
electoral
asumiendo que los porcentajes que el
kirchnerismo solía manejar antiguamente
entre el orden del cuarenta y el 50 por
ciento para esta oportunidad van a ser
menores oscilando alrededor del treinta
disputando conjuntos por el cambio la
tradicional coalición con la que viene
haciéndolo desde 2015 y con la nueva
fuerza libertaria de Javier milei ahora
el kirchnerismo heredado a la
vicepresidenta Cristina Fernández sigue
siendo ese mismo que nació hace 20 años
y además con la crisis dentro de la
formación estamos quizás ante una
transición política en las filas de
peronismo
sin ningún lugar a dudas Cristina
Fernández sigue siendo una líder
importante dentro del frente de todos y
del pan peronismo pero ya no con el peso
que solía tener antiguamente y de hecho
ha tenido que ver como este gobierno no
ha podido responder a las expectativas
de mejoras en los ingresos
fundamentalmente por el flagelo de la
inflación para el cual no ha tenido una
respuesta el capítulo de los tres
primeros gobiernos kineristas coincidió
con un alza de los precios de los
commodities y una situación que permitía
crecimiento y distribución el de los
últimos años no ha permitido ninguna de
las dos cosas el producto bruto de la
Argentina per cápita del 2023 es
equivalente al del año 2006 y la
inflación está en un registro anual de
tres dígitos Así que esto obliga a la
vicepresidenta a resetearse en la épica
de sus primeros mandatos
desligarse del actual presidencia y
encontrar un candidato que le permita de
alguna manera
enfrentar una difícil elección como la
de este año donde los guarismos no
acompañan a la coalición oficial Bueno
ya un cierre de a un mes de que cierran
estas filas electorales A qué se debe
que el oficialismo todavía no cuente con
esa figura con esa candidato definido
en parte a las disputas que Todavía
siguen manteniendo el presidente y la
vicepresidenta respecto a si tienen que
ir a las primarias con una sola fórmula
o compitiendo con dos o más
la vicepresidenta y el ministro de
economía Sergio massa que son los dos
principales socios de la coalición
sostienen la necesidad de evitar una
interna dentro del oficialismo el
presidente y algunos otros sectores
creen que una competencia entre por lo
menos dos fórmulas ayudaría para este
ampliar un espacio tan castigado por la
económica como no se ponen de acuerdo en
esto restan cuatro semanas para ver si
se impone la voluntad de la
vicepresidenta ya sea por la lista única
o porque ella privilegie una de las que
compita poniendo todo el poderío no solo
que tiene en términos territoriales sino
también en su propia imagen personal